is it helps us to test to see if a
triangle is a right triangle so it's
like seeing the Pythagorean theorem
backwards right so let's take a look say
they give us the three sides here four
five six they say does this form a right
triangle well first thing you want to do
is you want to make sure it forms a
triangle so you want to make sure that
any two sides add up to more than the
third side that's called the triangle
inequality theorem but you just want to
make sure that they're gonna form a
triangle so 4 plus 5 is 9 that's greater
than 6 5 plus 6 is 11 that's greater
than 4 and 4 plus 6 is 10 that's greater
than 5 so it does form a triangle but
now we're going to do is we're going to
we're going to test the converse of the
Pythagorean theorem so a squared plus B
squared question mark C squared now
which one C is it 4 5 or 6
well it's 6 6 is good the longest one
that's the one we're testing to see is
the hypotenuse okay that that's the
longest side in a triangle the right the
one across from the right angle the
hypotenuse so in this case we're going
to put six here we're gonna put four
here we're gonna put a 5 here I'm just
going to leave a question mark and let's
simplify we've got 16 plus 25 36 this is
41 which does not equal 36 so that means
that it's not a right triangle it does
form a triangle it's just not a right
triangle okay in the next video I'm
going to show you how to tell whether
it's a cute right or up to so check out
that video but let's do one more example
here they give us a triangle 9 12 and 15
still you want to make sure even though
they've draw it this way that it does
form a triangle so you add the two sides
up make sure it's more than that third
side so 9 and 15 that's more than 12 12
and 15 added together is more than 9 and
so on but we're gonna do the Pythagorean
converse we're gonna say 9 squared plus
12 squared does it equal 15 squared and
remember 15 is the one that we're
testing for the hypotenuse that's the
longest side so let's simplify we get 81
plus 144 15 squared is 225 15 times 15
and if we add these together we do get
225 it does equal to 25 on the
right sides so that means that yes this
is a right triangle that means this must
be a right angle right there